So in this lesson we've learned about two of the most commonly used methods in
psychological science, cor-relational and experimental designs. In
correlational studies, two variables are studied such as the amount of
housework and the number of sexual encounters. As it turns out these two things
were related but remember that correlations tell us only about the strength and
direction of the relationship. Not whether one causes the other. And
experimental studies, if done correctly, can shed light on whether one variable
causes another. But true experiments have to have two conditions met, first,
random assignment of participants to either a control or an experimental
condition. And if these two conditions are treated exactly the same. Except the
experimental group gets the treatment, or the predicted cause, whereas the
control group, does not, and serves as a baseline comparison. By giving two
groups different amounts of something, we're manipulating a variable. And this
leads to the second condition of an experiment. So the second condition of an
experiment is manipulation of an independent variable. And an independent
variable, we'll remember, is something that the investigator manipulates. So
for instance, the amount of caffeine given. The experiment also has a dependent
variable, or an outcome variable, in this case, it could be reaction time. So
if the amount of caffeine really does have an effect, we can say that our
independent variable, or caffeine, is the cause. And the dependent variable, or
reaction time, is the effect. And it depends upon the independent variable. So,
psychological scientists use these and many other kinds of research methods.
But the key is that psychology makes use of the scientific method to answer
questions about human nature, human thought, and human behavior. So,
psychological scientists can't do whatever they want in their research. They
have to do what's ethical and their proposals always have to be approved By an
ethics board or an IRB.